[Musique]
et voilà bienvenue dans ce nouveau
stream dans lequel on va lire ensemble
un article de sciences sociales et
aujourd'hui c'est l'article de Pierre
Perrier qui est mis à l'honneur alors
c'est un article que j'avais vu passer
via une publication de la revue Science
humaine dans cette revue là on nous
présentait une typologie des enseignants
vous le savez étant moi-même enseignant
ça m'a directement intéressé mais dans
l'article de sciences humaines il y
avait juste la description des quatre
types d'anciennes Nyons qui ont été
établis par Pierre Perrier j'ai voulu en
savoir plus et donc j'ai retrouvé cet
article qui a été publié dans la revue
éducation et société ici en 2022 c'est
donc tout frais et l'article s'appelle
sentiment de reconnaissance et rapport
au métier des enseignants du secondaire
approchent typologique
et donc vous pouvez retrouver cet
article sur la plateforme cairn comme
souvent
cependant vous savez que sur cairn si
vous voulez à bénéficier de l'entièreté
de l'article et que l'article date de
plus de fin de moins de 3 ans à ce
moment-là il est payant souvent quand
c'est plus de 3 ans c'est gratuit mais
ici voilà la consultation n'est pas
libre toutefois si vous êtes dans une
faculté ou via certaines bibliothèques
universitaires vous pouvez y avoir accès
aussi voilà
alors je ne vais pas diffuser l'article
parce que voilà je n'ai pas les droits
et donc j'ai simplement vous lire
quelques passages
de celui-ci
et je vous montrerai évidemment ce qui
est le plus intéressant il y a quelques
graphiques qui sont intéressants et bien
ça je vous les diffuserai à l'écran
voilà donc l'article parle de quoi et on
part du contexte dans lequel le métier
d'enseignant est très
peu valorisé ou en tout cas il y a une
perception de différents acteurs qui qui
pensent que il y a une dévaluation une
perte d'attractivité du métier
d'enseignant d'ailleurs si je demande
aux élèves s'ils veulent faire preuve
plus tard
majoritairement très majoritairement il
me répondent certainement pas et donc
d'où vient cette image dégradée c'est un
peu ce qu'on va se poser comme question
et si Pierre Perrier donc introduit nous
dit que la reconnaissance est définie
pour ce texte comme la conviction
acquise par un individu de sa propre
valeur à l'issue de différents processus
d'identification et on va tout de suite
qu'on aura un phénomène relativement
complexe
dont on va essayer de
décortiquer que l'on va essayer de
décortiquer pour y voir un peu plus
clair c'est le produit d'une vision
subjective portée sur soi-même à partir
des autres
quiconque ces autrui significatifs au
fondement du sentiment de reconnaissance
donc on est vraiment sur un processus
identitaire et l'identité c'est toujours
quelque chose qui est à la fois
personnel mais en même temps très lié
aux autres parce que on peut se définir
d'une certaine manière mais c'est
toujours le regard des autres qui
viendra confirmer cette définition et
les autres peuvent nous affûter de
différentes étiquettes qui vont
littéralement nous coller à la peau donc
souvent on pense que l'identité ça vient
de fond de nous-mêmes mais en fait c'est
profondément social et c'est ce qu'on va
interroger ici
de ce point de vue analysez le sentiment
de reconnaissance des enseignants
impliquent de l'appréhender à plusieurs
échelons à partir de multiples
références des élèves aux parents en
passant par le représentant de
l'institution scolaire et support de
diffusion d'une image de l'enseignant
dans les médias l'opinion publique ou
les politiques tout ça évidemment
rentrent en ligne de compte et
l'hypothèse qui est proposée ici est
formulé dès la page la deuxième page de
l'article l'hypothèse consiste ici à
montrer que le sentiment de
reconnaissance donc on est sur une
réalité subjective ce sont les individus
ici les enseignants qui vont penser
certaines choses se forcer l'individu
sur base
d'expérience et de rapports sociaux
impliquant à la fois d'identifier et de
hiérarchiser les sources du sentiment de
reconnaissance et d'étudier la manière
dont elle se conjugue au métier pour
construire des mondes enseignants
relativement homogènes et ici la fin de
l'hypothèse est particulièrement
intéressante parce qu'on va nous dire
qu'en fait il y a pas des enseignants
qui auraient une perception de leur
métier dévaloriser il y a différents
enseignants et certains ben voilà n'ont
pas du tout cette vision là donc on va
amener aussi de la complexité dans
cette représentation qu'on peut avoir du
métier dévalorisé
l'analyse présentée ici s'appuie sur une
enquête par questionnaire réalisé entre
2016 et 2017 auprès de 2200 3
enseignants du secondaire en poste dans
six académies contrastées complété par
une enquête qualitative de plus de 80
entretiens individuels dans une
sélection d'établissements donc là on a
une méthodologie assez classique où on
va lier à la fois des méthodes
quantitatives avec un questionnaire sur
quand même une population assez
importante avec des entretiens qui vont
permettre d'amener de la qualité et de
comprendre vraiment les logiques et les
représentations de chacun
le choix des académies effectués en
collaboration avec la DEPP Direction de
l'évaluation de la prospective de la
prospective oui pardon et de la
performance du ministère de l'Éducation
nationale viser à s'approcher sous
plusieurs critères d'une représentation
nationale donc on ne va pas pouvoir
interroger évidemment tous les
enseignants français mais on va essayer
que l'échantillon que l'on va traiter
soit le plus représentatif possible
d'une représentation nationale donc on
va essayer d'avoir un échantillon assez
diversifié qui va permettre de rendre
compte des différentes réalités qui
existent sur le terrain
l'échantillon retenu a été stratifiante
de la structure des établissements par
académie type taille éducation
prioritaire hors éducation prioritaire
donc on va essayer voilà d'avoir toutes
les académies tous les types d'académie
plutôt et de la taille des communes les
enseignants ont été informés par les
responsables académiques rectorat et
chef dans d'établissement et parcours
réel personnel pour les inciter à
remplir le questionnaire tout en
garantissant l'anonymat des réponses et
leur usage strictement scientifique
parce que si l'enseignant n'est pas n'a
pas une garantie par rapport
aux réponses qu'il va donner et que il y
a une possibilité de fuite par rapport à
la hiérarchie bien ça va engendrer un
certain billet on va pas s'exprimer
totalement librement donc là l'enquêteur
les enquêteurs doivent s'assurer que
l'enseignant à la certitude que toutes
les réponses qu'il va donner ne sont
utilisées que dans le cadre de l'enquête
ça c'est normal mais c'est important
évidemment de passer par là deux
campagnes d'enquêtes on est au moins été
nécessaires pour disposer de 1115
questionnaires intégralement renseignés
les taux de répondant variés selon les
académies par exemple dans 8% de
répondant sur l'académie de Lille et 25%
à Versailles
puis on peut passer à Bordeaux Nantes 24
19 Amiens 13% et Rennes 10%. les femmes
et les enseignants en éducation
prioritaire ont un peu moins répondu à
l'enquête j'ai déjà streamé cet article
sur twitch et on me disait dans le chat
que peut-être que c'est un public aussi
qui va se sentir moins légitime pour y
répondre
la représentativité sur l'ensemble des
critères n'est donc pas parfaite mais la
taille et la composition de
l'échantillon lui donne une rebustesse
statistique
permettant de dégager des tendances de
différencier des sous-groupes
d'enseignants selon les conditions
d'exercice et d'effectuer des
comparaisons la longueur du
questionnaire 180 questions soit 40
minutes quand même pour le remplir et la
diffusion très variable de l'information
selon les académies et les
établissements explique probablement une
partie des non-réponses diffusée en
ligne il comportait trois questions
ouvertes et des séries organisées autour
du rapport au métier et au statut à
l'établissement et à l'institution
permettant ainsi de caractériser les
conditions d'exercice le sens donné à
l'activité et la position sociale perçue
par l'enseignant le sentiment de
reconnaissance a été analysé au travers
de questions se rapportant à l'image et
à l'attractivité de la profession
à la considération accordée au travail
enseignant ou à la gestion des carrières
des promotions finales les jugements de
reconnaissance se forgent et s'expriment
sur base d'un double regard en interne
et ça c'est important donc il y a une
construction interne via l’école
d'établissement spectacle et en externe
via les parents opinions publiques
politiques ces deux dimensions d'analyse
ont conduit progressivement la typologie
combinant la reconnaissance
institutionnelle perçue d'un côté et le
sentiment de reconnaissance
professionnelle pour soi de l'autre donc
là l'auteur va faire des choix
théoriques en dégageant ces deux grands
facteurs structurants qui ont qui sont à
la fois le sentiment du travail bien
fait dans le cadre professionnel le
sentiment de sentir en tant
qu'enseignant efficace dans sa classe de
faire des choses de qualité des choses
qui permettent aux élèves d'apprendre et
de progresser
et de l'autre une reconnaissance
institutionnelle tient est-ce que je
suis considéré par l'institution à ce
qu'on me donne les moyens de mon action
en classe
et donc ça c'est vraiment ce qui va
structurer après la typologie vous le
verrez dans quelques instants une
question listant une série de
difficultés du métier a montré que le
manque de reconnaissance par
l'institution de l'investissement des
enseignants était la plus cité donc ça
c'est vraiment ce qui revient le plus
souvent comme remarque près d'un quart
23% des enquêtés l'ont sélectionné en
premier et 60% sur la base de trois
réponses précédant le nombre d'élèves
par classe ce n'est que 18,6% des
enseignants qui cite cet élément-là
comme une difficulté dans leur métier et
le manque de discipline est Nanterre des
élèves n'apparaît qu'en troisième
position à 17,7%. donc vous voyez que
cette reconnaissance de l'institution si
ce n'est pas majoritaire c'est quand
même la principale cause qui est ici
dégagée de difficultés
ce premier constat suggère d'identifier
les facteurs et les combinaisons de
facteurs qui part de là les différences
des propriétés sociales des enseignants
et de conditions objectives
d'enseignement auraient un rôle
explicatif sur la nature et l'expression
du sentiment de reconnaissance
évidemment voilà il y a des variables
personnelles des variables sociales qui
vont entrer en ligne de compte des
conditions un établissement n'est pas
l'autre et on sait que dans un
établissement il peut y avoir une
culture scolaire qui fait que mais ça
c'est pas le parti pris théorique de
l'auteur lui va rester sur ses principes
de reconnaissance institutionnelle et
reconnaissance professionnelle
plusieurs étapes ont permis de
construire théoriquement cette notion
selon une dialectique analogue à la
construction de l'identité sociale en
articulant la reconnaissance pour autrui
et la reconnaissance pour soi est là ici
notamment les travaux de Dubach et un
article de 2000
et cette question là cet objet là de la
construction de la double du double sens
de construction
identitaire
fait l'objet d'un fort consensus
critique et donc c'est pour ça qu'ils
qui va creuser ceci là
alors on nous donne quelques chiffres
94% 94% de ceux du secondaire estime
ainsi que leur travail n'est pas reconnu
par l'opinion publique 93% par les
politiques 91% dont un pourcents par les
médias
d'après l'enquête 62% des enseignants
expriment le sentiment que leur travail
est peu ou pas reconnu par les parents
40% déclare même de même propos
à l'encontre des élèves donc voilà sa
force quand même une légitimité à
utiliser cette reconnaissance par autrui
du métier d'enseignant
l'une repose sur la manière de juger son
activité en classe donc là c'est les
deux axes structurants et le sentiment
d'accomplissement et d'efficacité qui le
retire plusieurs questions relatives à
ces pratiques et relations partagées en
classe avec les élèves ont été proposés
pour recueillir le sentiment de réussite
qu'il s'attribue dans les tâches
suivantes gestion de classe aide à
porter aux élèves les plus en difficulté
capacité à motiver les élèves
manifestants peu d'intérêt aide à porter
aux familles pour soutenir la scolarité
de leur enfant elles ont permis
d'établir une échelle de reconnaissance
professionnelle pour soi c'est à dire de
mesurer la valeur que l'enseignant
accorde à lui-même
dans son métier s'oppose ainsi après
regroupement des indices de classement
opérés pour chacune des modalités un
groupe de 2 12,5% d'enseignants en
grande difficulté selon les divers
aspects de l'activité et un groupe de
18,5 % et en le sentiment de pleinement
réussir dans la complicement des actions
citées donc voilà on revient sur le
l'hétérogénéité du public avec des gens
qui sont sortent très très bien en
classe qui le vivent très très bien qui
pensent pouvoir faire leur travail ou
qui pensent le faire et d'autres qui
sont en grande difficulté
l'autre composante du sentiment de
reconnaissance pour soi a été appréhendé
par les attentes que l'enseignant
s’estime en droit d'obtenir de
l'institution à raison de son
investissement professionnel
ce rapport a été évalué à partir de
questions portant sur la correspondance
entre le travail et le salaire
estimez-vous que votre salaire
correspond à votre travail à la prise en
compte de l'investissement dans le
travail estimez-vous que la carrière
d'un enseignant prend suffisamment en
compte son engagement dans le travail et
à la reconnaissance du travail par le
corps d'inspection là aussi il y a des
contrastes très très forts d'un groupe à
l'autre puisque 14,5% des enseignants
adoptent une position très critique par
rapport à l'institution et ils sont 13%
à exprimer l'inverse plutôt satisfait de
ce qui se passe au niveau institutionnel
donc encore une fois là on a vraiment
une opposition dans le public enseignant
entre deux positions parfaitement
opposées et donc c'est ce qui va venir
structurer notre typologie dans laquelle
on va dégager des publications qui sont
tout à fait différents parce que pour
rappel voilà le parti pris de l'article
c'est quand même d'expliquer
comment joue la reconnaissance du métier
d'enseignant et ici on est bien nous
expliquer qu'en fait c'est plus
compliqué de simplement dire les
enseignants trouvent qu'ils ne sont pas
reconnus ou tout simplement le travail
d'un d'enseignant n'est pas assez
reconnu dans la société c'est beaucoup
plus compliqué que ça de la part
évidemment des enseignants ici
et on va pouvoir établir une typologie
des enseignants le typologie en fonction
enfin selon pour évaluer leur
reconnaissance et le sentiment de
reconnaissance du travail dansant du
métier d'enseignant une typologie des
enseignants a été construite à partir
des deux axes du sentiment de
reconnaissance pour soi professionnelle
et institutionnel on vient d'en parler
permettant de dégager quatre groupes de
poids inégal combinant variablement
l'une ou l'autre des dimensions la
méthode d'analyse adoptée et la
classification hiérarchique ascendante
donc c'est une technique statistique qui
va être utilisée ici et je vais vous en
montrer je vais vous montrer un petit
peu de quoi il s'agit pour que vous
compreniez bien la démarche
donc la classification ascendante
hiérarchique
en fait le l'idée ça va être de mesurer
des distances alors il y a différentes
possibilités de mesure ici la distance
de goher ou la distance par rapport aux
filles carrés
c'est de manière de faire qui sont
différentes mais par exemple ici on nous
dit on va avoir dans l'échantillon des
individus qui ont répondu ou qui ont
certaines caractéristiques donc ici la
première personne le premier individu de
ma population c'est un homme grand blond
étudiant et urbain et le second individu
c'est une femme grande brune étudiante
et rurale et donc en fait ce qu'on veut
faire ici c'est chiffré la distance qui
sépare les deux individus alors comment
on va faire selon comprendre la distance
de Bauer ici on va juste mesurer une
distance de 0,6 une distance absolue
serait de 0 et des individus
parfaitement similaires seraient
ça serait une distance de 1 et donc ici
comment on obtient une distance de 0,6
bah c'est tout bête en fait vous voyez
que sur les variables ils sont
grands dans les deux cas ils sont
étudiants dans les deux cas et donc en
fait on a une ressemblance de 0,4
puisque sur 5 critères
il y a trois mobilités qui vont varier
et deux qui sont identiques et donc on
va juste calculer c'est comme si on
disait il y avait 40% de modalités qui
sont qui sont identiques et donc ça fait
une différence de 60%. donc là la
distance de goher elle est très facile à
comprendre la distance du fidèle en fait
on va venir introduire la probabilité
par rapport à la population totale
d'avoir certaines caractéristiques et
donc ici en fait on va venir
complexifier la distance en
faisant un rapport finalement à la
représentativité de ce caractère là dans
toute la population donc voilà ça va
être un peu plus complexe mais c'est le
même principe tout ça pour en arriver à
ceci tous nos individus vont avoir
un coefficient comme ça de distance qui
va être calculé et on va simplement
regrouper les individus qui vont être
les plus proches
et donc de regroupement regroupement de
niveau en niveau on va réaliser une
typologie finalement on va réaliser un
dendrogramme
descendre pour vous montrer voilà comme
celui-ci dans lequel on va par exemple
ici avoir 5 groupes de regroupement en
regroupement de proximité en proximité
voilà c'est simplement ça qui est qui
est fait ici
dans cette classification hiérarchique
ascendante et donc un certain moment ben
voilà on aura des grands groupes qui
vont ressembler qui vont rassembler des
individus très proches c'est comme ça
que vont être construites cette
typologie la méthode d'analyse adopter
et la classification hiérarchique
ascendante elle consiste à effectuer des
agrégations progressives de groupes
d'éléments définis par les valeurs
obtenues les distances individuellement
par les enseignants sur les réponses
apportées à chaque série de questions
construisant la reconnaissance
professionnelle pour soi et la
reconnaissance institutionnelle bon ce
qui est un peu dommage c'est que dans
l'article on n'a pas forcément tout le
développement statistique et donc je
peux pas vous en dire plus combien de
questions ont été prises en
considération comment ça s'est
réellement passé c'est un peu dommage
mais voilà c'est c'est un peu le jeu on
n'a pas toujours ces éléments là quand
on lit les articles un peu de
l'extérieur et donc ici ils ont opté
pour l'établissement de quatre classes
et on obtient ceci donc pour comprendre
le graphique vous avez un axe qui est la
reconnaissance professionnelle pour soi
donc c'est-à-dire est-ce que
l'enseignant a le sentiment de bien
faire son travail est-ce qu'il est
content de lui et puis on a la
reconnaissance institutionnelle est-ce
que l'enseignant
apprécie ou trouve que il est reconnu
par l'institution à ce que il trouve que
son salaire les remarques qu'il peut
formuler sont sont prises en compte par
l'institution et donc là en mixant un
match en les deux on va avoir quatre
groupes tout d'abord on a un groupe de
profs les accomplis qui représentent
21,8% de l'échantillon qui à la fois
sont assez content de leur activité en
classe
qui pensent faire du bon boulot et qui
en même temps sont assez satisfaits du
soutien institutionnel qu'ils peuvent
recevoir
et donc ça ce sont les accomplis et puis
on en a qui sont très contents de leur
activité en classe qui pensent qu'ils
font de bonnes choses mais qui sont
critiques par rapport à l'institution
c'est ce qu'on va appeler les critiques
c'est les plus nombreux et donc il est
logique quelques en quelque sorte que on
est l'impression que les enseignants ne
sont pas très contents de leur situation
parce qu'en fait ceux qui ne sont pas
contents sont ici majoritaires les
critiques sont à la fois des profs qui
sont reconnus sans doute mais qui vont
faire porter une parole critique
on a les contrarié qui en classe ont des
difficultés avec leurs élèves peut-être
des difficultés de discipline des
difficultés didactiques à transmettre la
matière et les apprentissages qu'ils
veulent transmettre mais qui ne sont pas
forcément critiques vis-à-vis de
l'institution et donc ils en restent sur
une critique de leur activité propre
et puis les désenchantés qui sont
minoritaires ils ne sont 14,4% mais eux
sont à la fois très désabusés par
rapport à leur activité en classe mais
aussi trouve que l'institution voilà
n'est pas reconnaissant de leur activité
ne tient pas forcément compte de leurs
remarques et de leurs difficultés
voilà alors ce qui est intéressant après
c'est que on va continuer je vais
peut-être vous montrer directement ceci
on va demander aux enseignants de
résumer leur métier avec trois mots de
retenir trois mots qui pour eux résume
bien le métier d'enseignement
d'enseignant et donc après on va
replacer ces mots on va bien sûr les
uniformiser par exemple si on a utilisé
des des substantifs ou des verbes on va
par exemple le créativité ou créatif ou
création voilà on va le résumer sous le
terme créativité par exemple donc
l'auteur a bien sûr fait ce travail là
et puis il a replacé les mots en
fonction de de l'endroit où ils
apparaissent en fonction de ces
différents facteurs des différents
facteurs qu'on a
précisé précédemment et puis il va
attribuer une couleur pour retrouver les
facteurs tels sont formulés par les
différents groupes qui ont été établis
la typologie qui a été établie selon la
typologie qui a été établie et c'est
intéressant par exemple chez les
contrarié on voit qu'il y a des
questions de discipline qui apparaissent
de rigueur de transmission d'autonomie
alors personnellement
quand on lit une typologie comme ça
quand on prend connaissance d'une
typologie comme ça on peut s'empêcher de
replacer dans les cases des collègues ou
des enseignants qu'on a croisé et c'est
vrai que quand j'essaie de trouver dans
dans mon expérience des profs qui sont
contrariés et bien il parle souvent de
questions de discipline de questions de
rigueur d'exigence c'est vrai que je
retrouve beaucoup ça et puis chez les
désenchantés là on va avoir des des
considérations très pratiques très
pragmatiques
comme la paix comme un travail pénible
comme le fait d'être inadapté d'être
usé des difficultés voyez puisant on
sent ici vraiment tout un champ lexical
de la souffrance bon chez les autres
chez les accomplis et les critiques je
trouve que il y a pas forcément de
choses à retirer enfin en tout cas en
lisant comme ça rapidement si ce n'est
voilà des questions comme la passion
comme l'enthousiasme qui vont se
retrouver se sentir pédagogue patient
compétent voilà on va retrouver des
différentes qualités qu'il faut qu'il
faut avoir quand on est enseignant sans
doute
aussi le plaisir qui va se retrouver ici
bien qu'on soit chez les critiques on
peut voir différentes choses prises en
compte de la jeunesse aussi voilà ça
c'est assez intéressant alors finalement
l'auteur va terminer en nous proposant
des portraits et ça j'aime bien parce
que voilà faire des séances sociales
c'est aussi aller au contact des vrais
gens et ici on va avoir des portraits
j'entendais tout à l'heure encore un
podcast de pour Dieu qui disait mais
quand on rencontre des gens lors d'un
entretien qu'on leur fait leur
administre un questionnaire on a envie
de rentrer dans leur tête et de
connaître leur vie quoi en fait on a
envie de savoir quel est leur vie mais
c'est exactement ici ce qu'on va faire
puisque on va découvrir les portraits
dans saignant j'en prends un hasard je
les ai pas tous lu je découvre avec vous
on va prendre le portrait de madame C
professeur de mathématiques Madame C
professeur de mathématiques en fin de
carrière et en poste depuis 25 ans dans
le même lycée ses débuts dans
l'enseignement ont été difficiles alors
que le choix du métier s'est imposé
comme une évidence car j'aime faire des
maths dit-elle j'aime les transmettre et
j'aime voir un élève qui a du mal et qui
tout d'un coup va comprendre va
progresser
lorsque l'on interroge sur son activité
elle insiste sur sa mission
traditionnelle qui est évidemment de
transmettre la discipline que vous avez
choisi mais quelque part c'est aussi lui
l'élève donner le goût du travail c'est
lui donner lui montrer qu'on peut avoir
du plaisir à travailler la dimension
éducative s'impose également mais par
nécessité c'est leur dire aux élèves que
ben non on ne va pas mâcher le
chewing-gum en ouvrant la bouche devant
le prof on ne va pas bailler parce que
ça on ne le fera pas non plus quand on
sera dans le monde du travail et dans
certaines classes vous êtes obligé
d'expliquer tout ça quoi alors des fois
vous passez vraiment pour le prof pas
marrant elle regrette que l'école et la
société attribue de plus en plus de
tâches aux enseignants y compris selon
elle des choses qui ne sont pas de notre
ressort cette vision dépréciée du métier
renvoie des changements chez les élèves
qui n'ont plus le rapport au savoir et à
l'école qu'elle a pu connaître
antérieurement la majorité des élèves ne
savent pas pourquoi ils sont
ne veulent pas travailler ne comprennent
pas
que ça peut avoir un intérêt pour la
suite ils vivent au jour le jour les
conséquences s'observent dans les
comportements parce que tout en découle
aussi ces élèves-là du coup au niveau
discipline on va avoir des soucis avec
eux évidemment à partir du moment où ils
sont arrivés là ils n'ont pas les
compétences ça ne les intéresse pas et
ils vont essayer de s'occuper autrement
les difficultés de mise au travail des
élèves altèrent l'estime de soi et pour
moi ça c'est très dur j'aime mon métier
j'aime mon boulot je suis à trois ans de
la retraite j'aime mon boulot mais du
coup vous éprouvez un sentiment d'échec
vous-même quand vous rencontrez ce genre
de situation l'identité professionnelle
semble ébranler et laisse percevoir une
forme de souffrance au travail parfois
j'en ai ras le bol et puis il y a
d'autres moments où ça se passe mieux
mais ça peut finir très très mal vous
pouvez finir sous antidépresseurs et en
arrêt maladie donc il faut vraiment
faire la part des choses celui qui vous
veut voudrait être prof je lui dirai de
bien réfléchir je ne lui recommanderais
pas passe à ces épreuves multiformes C
ne se sent pas réellement soutenu par
ses collègues et c'est même un sentiment
d'isolement qui domine dans ses propos
pour autant la hiérarchie locale
l'administration de l'éducation
nationale semble épargner de ces
jugements critiques ce qui peut
contribuer à expliquer une certaine
satisfaction dans sa carrière je pense
que oui je suis satisfaite de ma
carrière d'enseignante oui oui je ne
peux pas dire que ça s'est mal dérouler
le monde des enseignants des enchantés
expriment avec force le sentiment de ne
pas être reconnu que ce soit par le
salaire ou par l'absence de
considération ce sentiment est associé à
un métier éprouvant marqué par la
pénibilité générant une forme d'usure au
travail le décalage semble radical entre
la conception initiale du métier et ses
conditions d'exercice au quotidien avec
des enseignants démunis et comme coupé
de tout soutien de proximité ou de
l'institution et là on va voir le
portrait de Monsieur D mais enfin ici
madame Madame C c'est plutôt le prof
voilà qui a peut-être des difficultés
dans sa classe mais ne comme on le dit à
la fin de du portrait n'est pas critique
par rapport à l'institution en général
et donc là elle fait pas plutôt partie
des contrarié et donc ici on va plutôt
avoir un désabusé
je reviens sur ma feuille
portrait de Monsieur D professeur
d'anglais
âgé de 25 ans Monsieur D originaire d'un
département d'outre-mer a été affecté
par défaut 21e vœu dans un collège de
l'académie d'Amiens où il enseigne
l'anglais pour la deuxième année il
estime que le personnel de direction
n'est pas forcément toujours à l'écoute
et prend pour exemple un acte de
violence commis par un élève je l'ai
signalé à l'établissement et j'ai eu
trois réponses différentes de la part de
trois personnels de direction différente
donc sur le moment je l'ai assez mal
vécu ce qu'on m'avait dit c'était de ne
pas m'inquiéter parce que je serai
toujours soutenu par le personnel si
jamais il y avait un souci et je me suis
rendu compte qu'en fait c'était
absolument pas le cas autre exemple de
ce manque de prise en compte de la
parole des enseignants le conseil
d'administration en conseil
d'administration lorsque les professeurs
représentants posaient des questions on
nous faisait comprendre que c'était des
considérations un peu triviales et
qu'elle n'avait pas leur place dans un
conseil d'administration et que si on
était là pour ça ce n'était pas la peine
donc du coup on se dit que non on n'est
pas écouté ça nous moins envie on
s'investit mais peut-être avec moins de
motivation moins de volonté on se fait
beaucoup piétiner en fait pour cet
enseignant il y a un décalage radical
entre la logique managériale et
gestionnaire de la direction et la
logique pédagogique des enseignants
entre le corps professoral et le corps
directionnel il y a une vraie cassure
ils sont dans l'optique de faire tourner
l'établissement comme des gestionnaires
ou des dirigeants Monsieur D s'attendait
également à davantage de soutien de la
part de ses collègues plus expérimentés
dans l'équipe disciplinaire on a des
collègues qui sont relativement âgés et
trois ou quatre collègues qui sont de
mon âge ou plus jeunes donc forcément on
a un faux serré générationnel entre les
deux et ceux qui sont là depuis beaucoup
plus longtemps forcément ils travaillent
dans leur coin dans la classe la
transmission des savoirs à des élèves
peut disposer implique des subterfuges
voir des renoncements proches du deuil
disciplinaire j'essaie de faire en sorte
que mes élèves restent motivés en fait
tout simplement j'essaie de mettre
beaucoup de ludique dans tout ça ce que
je fais pour qu'il s'amuse entre
guillemets en apprenant parce que si
c'est trop rébarbatif pour eux il lâche
ils ont besoin d'une pression s'ils ne
l'ont pas ils ne font pas et forcément
pour nous c'est frustrant parce qu'on ne
mène pas forcément à bien la mission
qu'on est censé mener dans cette
situation ce jeune enseignant perçoit un
profond décalage entre les attendus du
cuir l'homme prescrit et le curriculum
réel j'ai toujours un avis assez mitigé
honnêtement parce que si je me base
vraiment sur la recommandation des
programmes officiels clairement on est
loin au niveau de l'acquisition des
compétences par les élèves des savoirs
de savoir-faire ce professeur s'exprime
peu sur les relations avec les parents
mais il évoque le cas de ceux qui ne
suivent pas du tout leur enfant et pour
lequel il se trouve parfois sans
solution c'est un peu désarmants pour
nous à certains moments confronté à ces
épreuves qui se répètent il devient de
plus en plus difficile de tenir quand
bien même Monsieur D ne fait que débuter
dans le métier voilà un deuxième
portrait d'un professeur là qui rentre
plutôt dans la typologie désabusé
bien voilà vous avez l'essentiel de
l'article qui vous est proposé ici on va
peut-être lire quelques éléments de la
conclusion un résultat marquant de
l'enquête et que les différentes
expressions du sentiment de
reconnaissance des enseignants du
secondaire relève non de tel ou tel
déterminant mais de combinaison de
facteurs qui lui donne forme et
produisent une individualisation de ce
phénomène social multidéterminé
l'articulation entre les deux sphères de
reconnaissance construit des
configurations d'expériences hétérogènes
synthétiser dans des profils
typologiques allant des enseignants les
plus accomplis plus des enchantés elle
confirme ainsi le caractère à la fois
transversal et individuel de la
reconnaissance ou son versant subjectif
une individualisation qu'il convient
néanmoins de ne pas surestimer en
restant attentif à inscrire l'action
individuel dans un dans le cadre
collectif d'un établissement qui offre
un terreau plus ou moins favorable pour
la formation et l'expression du
sentiment de reconnaissance
voilà je vous invite à prendre
connaissance de l'article si celui-ci
vous a intéressé il y a d'autres
articles de Pierre Perrier qui ont été
d'ailleurs qui ont fait l'objet
d'articles dans la revue Science humaine
je me souviens d'un article qui traitait
des vacances dans le milieu populaire ou
Pierre Perrier établissait déjà c'est
peut-être une marotte qu'il a établissez
une typologie des différents types de
vacances ou des différents types de
personnes des milieux populaires par
rapport aux vacances donc vous
retrouverez facilement ça sur sur le net
et de toute façon dans la description de
la vidéo vous retrouver toutes les
références qui sont abordées d'autres
liens vers d'autres lectures de sciences
sociales bien je vous remercie je vous
souhaite de bonnes fêtes de fin d'année
et je vous dis à très bientôt